Tom Brady saying there's a lot of mocy
in today's NFL the rules have allowed a
lot of bad habits to get into the actual
performance of the game I look at a lot
of players like Ray Lewis and Rodney
Harrison and Ronnie lot and every hit
they would have made would have been a
penalty offensive players need to
protect themselves it's not up to the
defensive player to protect offensive
player without a doubt 100% agree the
league has went more into the offensive
league and I just don't think it's the
same love and protection towards
defensive players at that there's
players and there's teams that takes
advantage of these rules uh quarterback
can run at you full speed One play and
give himself up and then the next time
act like he's sliding or you may think
he's about to slide and he could Juke
out and you go with the same energy and
you hit him because you don't know if
he's fake sliding or he is sliding and
you might get a penalty and you might
get a letter in the mail because you you
late hit this quarterback I just think
it's outright ridiculous like you either
can hit the guy or you can't you're
playing football at full speed you're
not playing football at 50% I 100% agree
on what Tom Brady's saying